[Music]
the 2010s was a breakthrough decade for
non-ge anime films in my opinion
everyone and their friends already know
about movies like your name and Asylum
voice but in between those blockbusters
Japan has been releasing some cool anime
films along the way in addition to great
follow-up film titles such as Ghana
super Madoka Magica no game no life
fate/stay night and sword art online
there have also been some nifty films
such as anthem of the heart hello world
and macchia there's no reason why anime
films wouldn't ride that freshly gained
momentum into the new decade and just as
soon as the decade began we found
ourselves looking straight at a gallery
of anime films to look forward to 20 20
and 21 looked to be great years in terms
of anime films and mind you for just
talking about the first year or so of
the decade let this list convince you
that the anime film industry is as
strong as ever
hey skitty era ever felt the despair of
unrequited love it's a pretty common
trope in school anime but na keen echoed
the upcoming anime flick kicking off our
list goes around this dilemma just a
little bit differently as you can see
our protagonist meiosis aki has all the
traits of a likeable girl at school
she's energetic bright and madly in love
apparently these traits do nothing and
helping her get close to the one
classmate she has feelings for however a
true maidens loves not stopped so easily
not after she discovers a way to get
close to her classmate transforming into
a cat easy to say into but when the time
of reckoning comes how a mio overcome
the blurring of boundaries between her
two identities Nike Nico seems to carry
with itself a decent enough premise and
a set of intrigue that comes with such
setting we've seen anime cinema take
ordinary premises two promising new
heights in recent years so will Nike
Nico be the next one in line of great
anime films to reach blockbuster success
with great production value seen in the
trailer and renowned right to mario
karta on the team who's known for her
other works such as AnoHana
and macchia i believe there will be
given an anime film that will remain
memorable through the test of time
now with that mouthful of a title we
have our next movie featuring teenage
love this time things are a little bit
different the thing is here we have two
female protagonists Yoona and Akari with
different views on loved ones romantic
and idealistic view on love is
contrasted by the others more practical
and realistic approach the boys Kazumi
and Ryo don't have it any easier either
while one is dense and seemingly unable
to love the other jumps at the first
chance of answering a confession a world
wind of love is about to befall these
four people how are they going to cope
with the storms and joys of youthful
romance that may or may not meet their
expectations can this be the next a
silent voice hmm probably not but it
looks as promising and as good as anime
films go you sing too it's simpler
secure silikal to articulator eighth on
the list is Mobile Suit Gundam Hathaways
flash long time Gundam fans would
probably be familiar with Hathaways
flash set 12 years after chars
counter-attack the flames of war are
once again fanned by the emergence of
muftii a terrorist organization with
goals that run against the earth
federation at the helm is none other
than half the way Noah son of bright
Noah and pilot of the RX 105 Gundam
Hathaways flash is the movie adaptation
of the 80s novel it's gonna be a trilogy
of films with one film likely to cover
one volume each of the original novels
the ride just never ends with sunrises
cash cow franchise does it next to love
live of course fans can keep expecting
sunrise to deliver and this movie looks
consistently great across the trailers
that we've seen Hathaways flash hits
Japanese theaters this July and number 7
we have I fall in love with you through
a robot set in the future when the Tokyo
Olympics is at hand
the movie revolves around a secret
project using robots tragedy unfolds and
a terrorist threatens to consume our
protagonist Takeru and the heroine Saki
in a way some people have compared it to
hell I think the film will have more
twists that differentiate it from
similar premises for what it's worth the
art in the trailer and the preview look
amazing while have not read the novel's
for this one I'll definitely be eagerly
looking out for it the movie was
announced some two years ago meanwhile
we got a special one-minute animated
promo by a-1 pictures so I assume that
there'll be the same staff in charge of
the movie
way or another we haven't had much news
about this movie's release date as of
the time of this writing but a lot of
people are still eagerly awaiting if the
special received quite a lukewarm
response but with a movie production I'm
sure that we'll get a much more engaging
final product
sixth place this time is the violet ever
garden movie finer ever gardens in
interesting title in contrast to the
usual Moy titles that you expect out of
cure Ani they decided to take a crack at
a serious drama and they came up with
the title then I only received an
extremely warm reception but also pushed
the bounds of anime art and aesthetics
unsurprisingly violet ever garden got a
movie follow up announced after the
tragedy that befell KyoAni we are
finally getting to see the movie
follow-up to what's been a dramatic and
extremely esthetic series will violet
finally reunite with a source of true
happiness looks like we're in for an
emotional conclusion to the story of
violet ever garden if the music in the
art and the trailer are indications it
looks like johani brought their a-game
to this movie that marks their
triumphant return from tragedy we won't
have to wait long until we see violet
ever garden again
I'm sure the cure money can score once
again and give us a story to remember
[Music]
when bleach fans everywhere rejoiced at
the return of their much beloved anime
after almost a decade hiatus some of
them forgot that the announcement didn't
come alone
yeah but lost in the hype of the bleach
return is Kubo's other title his
one-shot spin-off manga burned the which
set in London burned the which takes on
a very familiar tone with two witches
Knoll and spanked Oh working for an
organization named winged bind the
organization fights dragons
all-too-familiar supernatural creatures
that apparently caused multiple deaths
in London the catch is that dragons are
typically unseen by the human eye so
it's up to witches from reverse London
to help Carl the dragon population and
keep London safe does it sound familiar
yet having read the manga I think that
burn the witch will do pretty well as a
movie the visuals look promising and I
think that being given a movie to handle
can help the team add even more details
to further develop the world of burn the
witch while we wait for the bleach
sequel to come in 2021 burn the witch or
to satisfy our craving of supernatural
and ghostly battles for the meantime
it's been a long journey for Gintama and
as they say every journey has a
conclusion
luckily for Gonzales loyal fanbase
that's been following the epic story for
so many years we'll be getting the last
chapters of the manga adaptation in the
form of a full-length movie talk about
ending with a bang huh after the dust
settled from the final battle against
dude sorrow peace and everyday hijinks
returned from kintoki and the gang now
that the ultimate enemy has already been
defeated watch awaits kintoki and the
rest of the eurozone turns out that we
get one last adventure to go through
before bidding the rest of the gang
farewell the movie set for a 2021
release yep you heard that right that's
a long way ahead for us isn't it on the
bright side the long wait will most
likely serve as enough time for the
movie team to patch everything up and
come up with top quality material of
course they can't afford to give a less
than excellent product given the status
of Gintama next on the list is fate/stay
night spring song the much awaited
finale of the route would have been
shown in Japanese theaters already but
as you know we can't have nice things
with a virus outbreak around so it's
been moved to a later April release now
that we've got that down or out of the
way we can look at the bright side it
took a long time for us to get there but
at last the heavens filled root of
fate/stay night comes to an end in a
climax worth all the weight and hype as
Sakura's tale comes to a close we can
finally see much of the awaited moments
fate fans have been hyping up such as
Shiro finally using arches arm in battle
the fated confrontation with dark Sakura
and rider going all-out in the climactic
fight against saber altar with UFO table
ready to produce magic for the third
movie in a row fate/stay night spring
song won't disappoint let's all wait in
anticipation for this closing chapter of
a timeless epic a waiting will surely
pay off with this one
[Music]
it's no surprise that the Demon Slayer
movie would be a part of this list its
level of popularity after the majorly
acclaimed episode 19 came out of nowhere
and the show just erupted onto
everyone's radars overnight demon slayer
craze is still at an all-time high
and it has a lot to do with not just the
climactic events in the manga but also
the announcement of a sequel in the form
of a film the demon slayer movie
continues the story and takes our heroes
onto the Infinity Train Ark where they
get acquainted with the mighty fire
pillar ring Goku as a staple in Shonen
anime things quickly go south as the
sinister demon n-woo seeks to trap the
passengers in his world of Dreams what
awaits our plucky group of demon Slayers
both during and after this ordeal the
hype is real and the world awaits the
release of this new edition to 2019 s
hottest anime with demon slayers immense
popularity only one anime movie coming
out in the next year could out hype it
now what could that movie be why it's
the legendary event galleon coming in
with its final movie in its series that
spanned over a decade the past decades
been a treat with this new high end
retelling of the classic tales with such
a long wait between movies I'm sure that
the fans will take nothing less than a
top-tier product for an answer after two
of the three movies received outstanding
reviews and critical acclaim I'm sure
that the final event galium film would
be a home run for the team will we get a
classic gainax ending will we get a
twist ending that leads to a reboot we
can only wait to see what Carl will pull
off this time round
I'm personally more excited to see the
reception after the film to be honest
I'm sure that seeing everyone's
discussions post film will be glorious
sheduled for a June release it's time
for us once again to return to the world
of Evangelion
the future looks really bright for anime
films and the same goes for the industry
as a whole if you want to learn more
about some top anime to look out for
do yourself a favor and like this video
and subscribe to this channel video 2
will be doing its best to bring you the
best previews for the hottest anime
titles in town with videos like this
[Music]
[Music]